After you have a good idea of what the system looks like, from the outside, and
how it is expected to behave, you can begin the architectural design process.
This involves decomposing the system in to it's components, and allocating
responsibilities to them. Now we did this before, when we did this exercise, but
that was an analysis model. Here, when we're talking about act, act,
architectural design we're actually going into the solution phase of things.
Now, one of the features of object oriented development is that it's often
the case that the particular elements that we come out of the analysis with,
our pieces there, translate into pieces into the architecture and
ultimately into the implementation. In addition to decomposing the system into
it's components, we have to allocate responsibilities to the components, for
handling those direct and indirect effects of the events, okay? And
we're going to express that using OCL invariants and pre and
post conditions. To indicate how those responsibilities are being satisfied